all right everybody let's jump into this
first story we got this from the post
millennial breaking Trump to appeal DC
trial date of March 4th calling it
election interference I have to agree
there they know exactly what they're
doing setting the state there's no
question about it they sure they try to
stop it I think it was Brian Kemp tried
to shut it down in Georgia and now at
the federal level like okay well we're
going to interfere by any means
necessary former president Donald Trump
torched special counsel Jack Smith as
well as federal judge Tanya chutcon in a
new post he put up on Truth social
Monday just hours after his official
trial date in Washington DC was set for
March 4th 2024 the day before super
Tuesday Trump suggested the actions of
both parties amount to election
interference and promised he would
appeal the decision saying
deranged Jack Smith and his team of
thugs who were caught going to the White
House just prior to indicting the 45th
president of the United States an
absolute No-No I like that have been
working on this Witch Hunt for almost
three years but decided to bring it
smack in the middle of crooked Joe
Biden's political opponent's campaign
against him election interference today
a biased trump-hating judge gave me only
a two-month extension just what our
corrupt government wanted super Tuesday
I will appeal he made a follow-up I was
saying page two colon
how do you have an indictment that is
based on what's entirely on the findings
of the January 6 unselect Committee of
marxists fascists and political hacks
when these same low Lives who have been
caught lying for years about Russia
Russia Russia Ukraine Ukraine Ukraine
fisa at the fake dossier much more
purposely and illegally destroyed and
deleted all of the evidence findings and
proof of the January 6 committee when
will deranged Jack Smith criminally
charge the committee
well there's no question in my mind and
I think any reasonable human being can
understand that when they set the trial
date for the day before super Tuesday
this will inhibit Donald Trump from
campaigning on the single most important
day of maybe even the whole election
because whether super Tuesday is huge
you're going to win the primary but the
votes the turnout we see in the primary
is it reflects the general election
Donald Trump won't be able to have
rallies or if he does it's going to be
at a courthouse
and it's going to give his opponents and
Joe Budden a tremendous Advantage they
know exactly what they're doing change
my mind well here's the thing about it
it's not just that it's super Tuesday
which is 14 States including Texas and
California it's also that they're
seeking to put a gag order on him to not
be able to talk about a lot of what's in
the case
so they already did gag him for some of
the stuff I think anything involving
Witnesses information about that that
comes out pre-trial but who knows if
they're going to file another motion to
try and stop him from having any further
discussions publicly about what's going
on in this case I think that's a really
big concern as well especially when he
comes out saying that it's election
interference they don't like that and
you also have
um you also have a lot of people saying
that his posts on Truth social
constitute a level of violence like when
he says if they come for me I'm coming
for you and they think that you know
like NPR thinks that that's violence
when really what that is is like also
law fair you know it's like further
legal implications well then that also
implies that they're coming they see
they're coming for him as violence yes
of course they do because they think
words are violence because they think
words are violence they've already told
us this right all through 2020 words are
violence all the pronoun people words
are violence it's it's it's a ridiculous
concept when the when these far leftists
are like words are violence and then
they insult you and call you a name
because by their definition your
response should be what they describe as
self-defense yes which is violence right
you have to go loot things if you've
been insulted you have to go lose
it's important no I tend to agree with
you I think he's certain to win the
nomination at this point I I don't see a
scenario in which he doesn't you know
pass away or something like that that
doesn't result in him getting the
nomination this is more about having the
pretense or the pretext to be able to
like you said to gag them to make it
where he can't talk about what promises
to be if not the single biggest election
issue one of the biggest ones while he's
campaigning
well yeah and they just turned over what
like I think uh 12 million pages of
discovery I think that came out today as
well 12 million Pages it doesn't seem
like a real amount it's like when Saddam
says the 0.8 million pages of discovery
that the doj have in the in the
documents case every third page is just
like a recycled article from like a
1970s playboy or something hoping nobody
notices well that's the that's the thing
that's what discover Y is like a lot of
what they do in Discovery when they
don't want you to do well in your case
is they hinder you by giving you too
many boxes they give you like everything
that they can come up with and they say
it's in here and then you're going
through it all yeah we can't tell you
where you'll you'll find it on your own
it's in there no it's in there yeah
whatever it is it's hard not to think
that the gag or any gag order imposed on
Trump would be broadly interpreted too
so even if for some reason he could be
you know at a campaign rally they're
able to say will you reference the last
election which of course he would
because campaigning for president and
they'll say no you're in violation it
seems obvious that they're trying to
trap him into potentially facing more
more charges I'm I'm torn between
whether or not they want him in jail
when they want him in jail I think they
do but I don't know if like these
Democratic leaders are in alignment on
when and how because if Donald Trump
went to jail now it would be a massive
boost for his campaign but it's really
hard to predict exactly what would
happen like if they remanded him to
custody it would inhibit his ability to
campaign but the Press would be so
explosive that it might make more money
for for him than
he did like seven million dollars off
the Georgia mug shot right and I think
that was like yesterday's number or
something yeah that was yesterday's
number now they they have remanded black
voices for Trump his name's Harrison
Floyd so he cannot campaign campaign and
he's the only one yeah what was their
justification for only they're just
sailing the black up the black guy you
know they wanted to improve the judicial
system is racist I'm surprised that no
one caught that right away because I
remember when I saw the news that he was
being remanded I'm like like the only
guy they were Amanda is the black dude
like these 19 people yeah yeah and then
and then I think we mentioned on the
show and everyone laughs and I'm like
well you guys didn't like I thought
everyone just noticed they did that yeah
your Tweet was the first thing I saw on
that and I was like oh no because Libby
doesn't see color that's the thing but
this is like a 4D chess thing they're
saying see we told you this system is
systemically racist
told you we told you that because we do
it yeah because we are racist we know it
well there was that poll uh I saw a
screenshot from Fox News and I didn't
see a headline reflecting that
particular aspect of the story the
headlines were all like Trump improves
and then you can read the poll and see
that Trump is enjoying 20 support among
black voters according to Fox News
I don't believe it
I don't I don't trust these polls
because uh uh but far be it for me to
say outright it is completely wrong Wall
Street Journal I think it was a year ago
found the exact same uh almost the same
thing 17
and uh uh several months before a month
or two before that found that Latinos
and Asians were also skewing towards the
Republican party and it may not be that
they're skewing towards Republican party
but the left is going absolutely insane
and the Democrats saying things like we
know gas prices are high but sacrifice
for Ukraine kind of drives voters insane
and they're gonna be like at this point
I thought whoever offers me anything
give me a ham sandwich and I'll vote for
you right so I do think it is possible
these numbers are real and there was a
lot of propaganda videos people put out
where it's you know like black dudes
saying like yo I'ma be free which i i f
with Trump man yeah coach I'm like yeah
okay dude like come on you find a
handful of guys it doesn't mean these
polls are real the reason fun videos
though they're fun but the reason I'm
skeptical is if this is true Trump can't
lose yeah there was actually something
that came out this would have been back
in like 04 or 05 that said that if uh
black support if everything else
remained equal all other demographics
remain equal if black Democrat support
went below 80 percent there isn't a
single state that they could win an
election a federal election or a
Statewide election
Wall Street General wrote that up uh
referenced it a couple years ago yeah
well and that's why it was so
significant when Trump gained like even
two percentage points between 2016 and
2020 among black voters I mean he is
this was like Edison and Pew research
that found it but he is more likely to
have support from black men than black
women but especially in this you know
four-year Gap that we've had Biden it's
it wouldn't surprise me if he maintained
the the stamina that he had produced in
the four years he was in office it was
funny we had a fresh and fit on the show
on Friday
and uh fresh was telling us that Trump
getting this mug shot is gonna resonate
with a lot of people who felt that
they've been in uh unjustly incarcerated
they're going to see this guy who's
being unjustly incarcerated it's gonna
resonate with him he's going to earn
their vote now today I saw this
narrative where they're like how dare
you insinuate this has been coming up
all over the place that I've been
playing with this myself yeah because
Trump was put in jail he'll gain black
support as if all black people have been
in jail and it's like well hold on there
a minute yes hold on they're they're
they are so I can't speak for anybody
else I can just tell you what we talked
about on uh the podcast with fresh and
fit but yo fresh is a black man telling
me this and he was referencing
specifically people who felt unjustly
incarcerated not all black people now I
don't know where the other narrative
like maybe someone said something else
I'm not going to say that that idea came
from this show but people are saying it
and now they're getting offended that
it's racist to imply I suspect he's
going to get at least a little bit of a
boost in Black support if for no other
reason than he created the greatest rap
album cover art ever like
that that mug shot yeah yeah I've been
hearing this from people that it's like
basically racist to say that a mug shot
would engender support in the black
community but by the left's own numbers
right by the Democrats own numbers black
people are but proportionally by
population more imprisoned more
disproportionately yeah
disproportionately imprisoned locked up
you know unjustly treated in the system
and so now they're like you could see
someone else is being unjustly treated
in the system oh just like me and my
brother and whoever else and I think
that it's true like a lot of Americans I
think have been arrested you know most
of the men that I know have been
arrested at some point spend the night
in jail whatever else but look at stop
and frisk the Democrats screamed that
was racist and then when Bloomberg was
made he was challenged as mayor he said
well look where the crime is you know
that's where the Democrat that's what it
says and it's like he's just he's just
saying too bad yeah if the Democrat
if the Democrats are complaining saying
that black people are disproportionately
targeted by police and then someone says
I think that might benefit Trump that is
being he's being uh unjustly you know
charged it's absurd that people like how
dare you but of course Democrats what
else can you expect from them but utter
hypocrisy I think it's the bending of
the logic they'll be like well Trump
could never experience the things other
people could experience like because
he's whatever white and privilege I I
think part of it is you know
as you watch him get buried in all this
legal bureaucracy getting 12 million
documents sent to him people identify
their own challenges with law
enforcement and the legal system right
they just see that like this is not a
system that is meant to give you uh a
swift trial it's not something that
necessarily uh is fair and it's not
necessarily a racial thing so much as
people who find that the system is
broken is seeing that no one is safe
from it trump it was the president of
the United States and they're going to
do whatever they can to try and keep use
this this arm of the government to keep
them out as a previous president it
could happen to anyone yeah it is
interesting too that the doj has been
trying to accelerate the timelines and
the cases that they're doing that
they're Prosecuting and Georgia and New
York both seem to be stretching it out a
little bit you know it's like Georgia
and New York want to get convictions
after the doj gets conviction so that
they can use those convictions in their
case even Alvin Bragg got permission to
use Trump's testimony in the E Gene
Carroll case for his falsification of
business documents case which of course
I just want to point out Hillary Clinton
got charged with falsification of
business documents she was fined eight
thousand dollars the DNC paid a hundred
and thirteen thousand dollars that was
for the creation of the Steele dossier
which they classified as legal fees
they got that and Trump's facing that's
multi-layered right they they get one uh
trial date I think uh in Georgia you've
got kind of chaseborough October 23rd
they will use all the testimony from all
of these and they'll keep layering it on
the first mission to inundate Trump's
sphere of influence with legal
challenges that drain their resources
and inhibit them from rallying
campaigning the second of course is to
just put them in jail to get rid of them
and another large component is maybe the
lastly it's get them in jail if we have
to but the other large component is can
we utilize any of this testimony to
remove Trump from the ballot thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time